kind of look like little mini hats in a
way I think they're great I think
they're they can be very practical this
is much larger than my nipple it's a
sizable part of my boob actually
my friend and I were at Burning Man and
she left her pasties on for a day and a
half and they actually started to take
off the skin
I think of Miley Cyrus when I think of
pasties like rocking it I think this is
gonna be pretty scandalous I'm ready for
my for my nipples to shimmer like a like
a little slick little star I don't know
why we have to cover up but guys don't I
don't understand why the nipple is the
weirdest part of the boob my mom always
said I had nipples like my grandmother I
never really understood with them it I
feel free there's like nothing on me
this is so you know I was hoping with
these green stars I would get kind of an
aerial look like a little mermaid look
but it really just it's not doing
anything for my boobs at all I feel like
if somebody was here I'd just like shake
my boobs in their face oh my god these
are so big that it almost looks like a
really tiny bikini I am the most letdown
of a stripper there ever was they're
like why did you put these on us I can't
stop looking at them I don't want to
like turn away if you're gonna go this
far you might as well just go all the
way and show your nipples so much more
movement can happen with this you'd have
to wear it for a long time for it to be
worth it and I don't think I could I'd
really want to go without my bra for
that long
I think that the nipple should be free
in that we shouldn't say that oh if you
show one centimeter more of your breast
you are like [ __ ] bad or wrong or
dirty but if you show one centimeter
less it's totally fine it's sexy fun
though I think that every chick should
have some pasties
I guess if they make you feel sexy you
should wear them